buenos días 70 jefes de estado y de
gobierno de todos los gobiernos de la
unión europea y de la unión africanos se
encuentran aquí en bruselas para
realizar revitalizar las relaciones
entre ambas regiones esta reunión no se
celebraba desde 2014 donde la región el
continente africano ha cambiado por
completo en cuestiones como la seguridad
como por ejemplo el terrorismo en el
sahel pero también la migración la unión
europea quiere volver a formar parte y
tener un papel dentro del continente
africano sobre todo para contrarrestar
tal y como comentaba es la influencia de
china y de rusia la comisión europea de
hecho presentó en septiembre una
iniciativa conocida como portal global
una iniciativa de infraestructuras que
pretende movilizar trescientos mil
millones de euros pero sólo la mitad 150
mil millones de euros quiere que la
unión quiere la unión europea que vayan
y vayan a parar al continente africano
se trata de inversiones por ejemplo en
transportes pero también para modernizar
la sanidad en el continente y así
también hacer frente a la conocida como
ruta de la seda china también se
abordarán temas como la migración
considerado de suma importancia para la
unión europa sobre todo para aumentar la
cooperación con los países del norte de
áfrica así como la crisis del cob y 19
la donación de vacunas la unión europea
quiere donar más de 300 millones de
dosis de aquí a mediados de 2022 hay que
recordar que cerca del 80% de los
europeos está totalmente vacunado pero
tan sólo el 11% del continente africano
lo está por lo tanto todo el mundo
también estará muy pendiente por la
cuestión de la liberalización de vacunas
que los próximos días se hablará en la o
mc pero la unión europea hasta ahora
siempre lo ha rechazado en la reunión de
hoy están prácticamente todos los
líderes de la unión africana no así los
líderes de malí ni de burkina faso donde
recientemente ha habido golpes de estado